back now to the escalating conflict in
Ukraine joined by Ukrainian MP Lisa
yasko hello to you msiasco thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
you are presently in uh Strasbourg
aren't you in France tell us why
good morning well today and this week
there is a parliamentary session of the
Council of Europe when we are going to
vote for the resolution on the Russian
consequences in Ukraine and that
atrocities that Russia is currently
committing in Ukraine so we're working
very hard to make everything possible
that as many countries as possible
recognize Russia as terrorist State and
that we create a real humanitarian
solutions that will protect the human
rights and will make sure that we have
the exchange of the war prisoners
release of political prisoners there is
a lot to be done this week here in
Strasbourg who's listening are are
people open to what you're saying
definitely uh but uh you know the world
used to be very different before this
war and sometimes we lack mechanisms how
how can we do it because yes there are
different monitoring missions there are
resolutions but you know when we vote
for them in the end Russia doesn't care
which means that in the end it's all
about the military support and inventing
completely new uh tools of providing
security to the world order right now
this is what we are doing this is what
is the role of Ukrainian delegation
right now because we know it uh better
than anyone what does it mean to live
with the War and what exactly should be
done to make sure that other countries
also don't get into this terrible
aggression from Russia
our spy Chief here in the UK yesterday
made a speech and said that he we would
know before there was any uh major
concern about the use of nuclear weapons
does that offer you comfort
well
um no I don't think it can offer me a
comfort because
um the threat of nuclear war is very
very high we understand that Putin
doesn't have any logic anymore it's not
possible to justify Putin anymore we
understand that he is in his final
battle of his life where he wants to
prove to all the world that he can do
whatever he wants including taking lands
killing thousands of people destroying
infrastructure and we are
we understand that nuclear uh threat and
strike is is very possible but it's not
going to change a lot on on the scene of
Ukraine of course it's a disastrous it's
a catastrophic
for me it's a big tragedy to see
thousands of people being killed uh
wounded destroyed lives
but it's not going to change the will of
Ukrainian people to restore Justice and
to restore our territorial sovereignty
we know that um Your Leader president
zielinski spoke to the G7 leaders
Yesterday by video link
um what do you think he took out of that
do you think he is getting or that
you're all getting the support that you
so desperately need from The Wider world
well I'm sure that every speech of
zelensky is very much needed right now
because it absolutely reflects the needs
and and and the mood and the situation
inside Ukraine I know that sometimes
some Western countries they are just far
and they don't feel the urgency which is
in incredibly frustrating for us because
you know we don't have time for
discussions we are screaming we're
trying to to to do everything possible
to defend uh with our weapon our people
every second and you know having this
kind of discussions that last long
for us of course it's not something
that's that's that is bring brings us
lots of happiness but of course I'm very
happy that there is a connection and a
communication bilateral and with the G7
with the different formats uh on a daily
basis even often this is
this is very important yeah this is very
important okay uh we must let you get
back inside and carry on with your work
thank you very much indeed for joining
us Ms Jessica thank you
thank you thank you thank you